our next guest wanted to be an astronaut
fun fact and her name means son in
French Please welcome my old friend
someone I'm so excited to see it's
Soleil Moon fry
you just inspire me so much and can I
say your designs beautiful I think I
love that your dog's licking my legs
this is the most action I've had enough
I was gonna say just wait wait until
Lucy comes up you'll be seeing plenty
more action
um okay we're kids of the 90s
the 90s are like back on the runways
it's all on Trend walk down memory lane
with me I think we're gonna rate
ourselves in a little game of Soleil or
nay
[Applause]
all right let's look at three of our
adventures from the 90s and we can
decide if we slayed or it was a nay
first let's look back to the early 90s
oh my God oh my God oh you guys I mean I
I get to rate this yes I can't read it
oh my God for me this is
[Applause]
all right here's one of mine look at how
gorgeous you are
slaying it got my worst slaying it all
right next another look from the mid 90s
oh my God oh my gosh
okay I was slaying it that way
um okay here's my look let's see how
this Compares oh it's so cute I mean I
look ready for a night out and you look
like you had a great night out exactly
I probably did all right uh our last
look from the late 90s slay arnay oh
okay this I oh I like this and you're
feeling it yeah you could not look more
beautiful what you photo am I coming up
with here oh my God
we're going we're slaying okay so we're
gonna take a little turn because we're
both working with GSK and you've teamed
up with them on their ask to be sure
campaign how is it empowering parents to
keep their kids safe funny enough we're
talking all about this right it's it's
been so incredible and it's been so much
fun because I've been working on it with
my 17 year old daughter so for me as a
parent I assumed the kids had gotten
meningitis vaccinations when they were
little and not realizing they're
actually two different types of
vaccinations needed to help protect
against meningitis I just assumed the
kids had been vaccinated for meningitis
when they were younger and didn't
realize that meningitis B was totally
different
and so it's really about raising
awareness so that people can have these
conversations and then talk to their
health care provider and this you know
disease although uncommon is incredibly
deadly and one of the groups that it
affects most is 16 to 23 year olds but
you know growing up again like I don't
think Health was the first thing on my
list to prioritize and now as a parent
it totally is and I'm always educating
myself so like thank you for bringing
this to my attention visit has to be
sure.com for more information I love you
so much I love you so much
[Music]